- Good afternoon, everyone,
and welcome to our session.
I'm Ravi, Senior Solutions
Architect at AWS,
and today I'm joined by
Brian-Lloyd Newberry,
Associate Vice President,
Enterprise Architecture,
and Tabare Gowon, Lead
Architect, Cox Automotive.
Just a quick question before we dive in.
How many of you are experimenting
with AI agents in your organization?
And keep those hands up
if you have launched one
to production and operating at scale.
You see the drop?
That's what we're gonna talk about today,
and you'll see Cox Automotive's blueprint
for addressing this challenge.
So here's the agenda.
I'm going to do a quick intro
of Amazon Bedrock Agent Core,
then hand it over to BLN,
who will talk about Cox
Automotive's agentic AI journey
and their success blueprint.
Tabare, then we'll walk you through
a reference implementation,
key considerations,
and lesson learned from the trenches.
We'll stick around for
any Q&A, so let's dive in.
So the biggest challenge
we see getting your agents
from prototype to production.
What are AI agents anyway?
They're autonomous
systems that can reason,
make decisions, use tools to take actions
in order to perform goals autonomously.
Your POC works great, but
there are five key challenges
that you must address.
Runtime, you need scalable infrastructure
to run long-running workflows
with complex orchestration.
Without the performance
overhead and the cost overruns.
Agents need to maintain context
and to have a meaningful conversation
with the end customer across the sessions.
So you need to have a
server-managed memory offering.
Agents, you need to
secure access to agents,
the tools they access, and the data.
Agents need a mechanism to
discover your existing systems
through agent-ready tools
and talk to other agents seamlessly.
And because agents are
non-deterministic in nature,
you need complete visibility
into their execution
so that you can trace, debug,
and evaluate their behavior.
Let me use an example
to drive this better.
So picture a service technician assistant.
A customer walks in with
a check engine light.
The technician takes
pictures of the dashboard,
perhaps records the engine noise,
and keys in customer concern.
The agent uses this data,
looks at the knowledge
sources, like OEM manuals,
technical service bulletins,
recall notices, and so on,
in order to come up with
a proper diagnostic plan.
The technician starts working on it,
and the technician finds something else,
then the agent has to adapt
and make a different recommendation.
So you see this back
and forth that goes on
to adapt and diagnose the car.
The service technician assistant
determines that they need
parts to fix the car,
then the agent goes and
checks the internal system,
pricing, inventory, availability,
and keeps customer preferences in mind.
This customer prefers quality OEM parts,
or this customer is budget conscious.
And then recommend the parts.
And if parts are not in stock,
perhaps agent has to log into
legacy supplier applications,
web applications, and place order.
So this repair can take hours,
and the agent maintains
a session throughout.
And when the customer returns weeks later,
the agent must remember everything
to resume the diagnostic process again.
So now imagine this whole
infrastructure scaling up,
supporting multiple technicians,
addressing multiple customer problems,
and with full session isolation.
And you need to trace every single step,
how an agent recommended a
particular diagnostic step,
and what sources it used.
For complete debugging and evaluation.
So without these capabilities,
we believe you are stuck
in the prototype mode.
And that's the gap AgentCore fills.
So AgentCore offers five
fully managed services
with two special purpose tools.
Runtime is secure,
scalable, and serverless.
It supports multi-modal inputs,
up to 100 megabytes of payload,
with long running sessions
up to eight hours.
You can use any framework
to build the agent,
and you can use it with any model.
Memory offers a short-term memory
for storing the conversational state,
and long-term memory to extract,
to learn from customer
interactions and adapt.
There are out-of-the-box strategies,
such as user preferences,
semantic facts, and summarization.
You can use those strategies,
override them, or bring your own strategy.
Identity provides secure authentication
and credential management.
It supports OAuth and IAM out-of-the-box.
And Gateway converts your existing APIs
and Lambda functions as
agent-ready MCP tools,
and provides a built-in
semantic search mechanism
for intelligent discovery.
Observability gives
you complete visibility
into agent's path trajectory,
with out-of-the-box CloudWatch dashboards,
and integrates with your
existing observability stacks
via open telemetry format.
Browser enables the agent
to perform complex web automation tasks,
and Code Interpreter allows agents
to run ad hoc complex calculations
in any language in a secure sandbox.
So we believe this is the infrastructure
that gets your agents into production.
With that, I'll hand it over to BLN
to walk through Cox Autos
Agentic AI Blueprint.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- You all hear me okay?
Good.
So my name is Brian-Lloyd Newberry,
and everybody calls me BLN.
If you wanna know why,
come up after the talk,
and I'm happy to tell you.
I have the privilege of leading
the Cox Automotive Product
and Technology Innovation Lab.
Me and a small team have,
for the last three years,
been completely embedded in generative AI,
and in this journey to move
toward agentic software.
I wanna start by just introducing
you to Cox Automotive,
'cause you may not understand the brand,
you may not understand Cox
Automotive as an entity,
but who here has shopped for a car
or bought a car anytime, right?
Not everybody, right?
But if you've heard of
brands like autotrader.com
and kellybluebook.com,
you're running into some of
the largest consumer portals
in the automotive industry.
People use them to buy vehicles
every single day, and so we
get a lot of traffic there.
We do websites for the
majority of the OEMs,
the automotive manufacturers,
in the United States,
so we see a lot of web traffic there.
So in the consumer space,
we see a ton of consumer
information coming together.
We also provide liquidity
in the automotive market.
If you've ever traded a car in,
you probably have had that car liquidated.
The dealer took it
through Mannheim Auctions,
sold it, and bought other
cars from Mannheim Auctions
to sell to other people.
We also offer an entire
suite of dealer software,
things like ERPs, custom CRMs,
inventory management, and the like,
as well as a suite of
finance applications,
and we're moving into mobility
and other spaces as well.
We're the dominant player
in the automotive industry
for software providers.
Because we have that much
visibility in the industry,
we have a view of everything happening.
We see the automotive
industry every single day.
Just as a round number, we get
about 5.1 trillion insights
about vehicles in the market.
We see hundreds of millions
of customer interactions
as people look at vehicles,
they get their vehicles.
They get serviced and move
through that life cycle.
And we provide all of, we
take all of that information,
which is the lifeblood of AI,
and we wrap AI models around it.
We've been doing AI for quite a while.
We have hundreds of AI
models in production.
I think 150-something was a
threshold we crossed last month.
Some of those might be agentic.
All right, so what I wanna do today
is tell you how, as an
organization, you can get moving.
One of the things we see as
we work with product teams
across the organization
and engineering teams
is there's a lot of
playing with agentic AI.
Although, most of the time,
people are just playing with
assistants, not agentic AI.
And so there's a lot of generative AI
and sort of like noodling
around the edges.
But people don't really know
what is an agentic application
and how do you get moving
and how do you build it.
Our chief product officer has this saying,
"Start with crazy and work backwards."
And so I'm gonna tell you
about a crazy experiment
we ran this past August.
And then Tabare's gonna show you
how one of the specific
projects that we kicked off went
and then we'll wrap it up.
As I said, we've been in
this journey a long time.
Mannheim, our auction provider,
has been around for probably
80 years at this point.
I should know that number
off the top of my head.
Sorry, Roger.
We've been, in 2018,
we went all in with AWS
and migrated from 50 data
centers down to three
and the rest running in AWS
regions, both east and west.
We've been doing predictive
AI for a very long time
using traditional machine learning models.
And Kelly Blue Book, that little book
that people used to literally buy
to look at the price of used vehicles
was a mathematical compilation
of vehicle valuations
that's going back 100 years.
In 2023, something happens.
So November 30th, 2022, Chat
GPT was released by OpenAI,
that the Chat GPT-3 model went live.
That created a ton of buzz.
Again, we knew that these
models were out there.
We've been looking at them.
Created a ton of buzz.
And what happened is in March of 2023,
we went all in on generative AI.
We took this team that
I'm leading right now,
we threw us in, and within a month
had access to multiple providers,
models in our environment.
We built a sandbox.
We started to build products.
And in the following year, we
had three major products live,
one of which saved about $750,000 a year
by just eliminating the need to pay
for content to be
generated someplace else.
And our content was better and faster.
And then we went in with
products for dealers
that increased response
rates from customers by 50%.
And we did other products as well.
On top of, to power that
generative AI model,
we really focused on our data
and bringing all of our data together.
And in 2024, on the way
back from Amazon re:Invent,
we launched a new initiative.
We set up a couple of teams
to go in and dive into the agentic space
and get ahead of the industry.
There was a lot of FUD
and excitement there,
but there wasn't a lot of meat behind it.
And we did a ton of work.
We were really successful driving through
building internal apps,
doing proof of concepts.
But we were kind of stuck.
We didn't really get a lot of
pull through on our products.
We had some.
We had four or five products
using generative AI in production.
A couple of them internal,
the rest external.
But we weren't seeing the pull through
from our product teams.
People had things they needed to deliver.
They didn't wanna disrupt
what they were doing.
People were scared.
I bet you if you went,
if we all sat down and
asked what an agent is,
there would actually be some debate.
Agentic applications, people
think about as a chatbot
with an AI, a generative
AI interface strapped on.
And that's a very naive
version of agentic AI.
Google deep research being,
or deep research in all
of the deep research tools
being one of the first examples I saw
of the true power of this kind of system.
But going back to Newton's principles
from high school physics,
you've got inertia,
momentum, and reaction.
So what you need to do
is you need to figure
out how to get moving.
If you're not changing anything,
nothing is going to change.
You have to get moving.
No one is an expert at
building agentic AI systems.
Like, it's been around for a year, right?
And having a PhD in math doesn't help you
because it's a soft skill.
It's looking at systems,
doing systems modeling,
writing text that helps
guide these LLM systems
to do things.
Just pick something and
get your teams moving.
So let's talk a little
bit about the craziness.
So the second, end of
the second week of July,
MJ said, "I wanna launch
five products by Labor Day."
And there are gonna be
agentic AI products,
brand new product capabilities in market.
And we said, okay.
Now we'd been building things,
we knew we could do that,
but we had five weeks to do
it and the teams that we had
had never built agentic AI apps before.
Well, Tabare and team
had built a little bit,
but they were a little ahead
of the curve, but not very far.
So we were starting from ground zero.
What do you do?
Your chief product officer and EVP
of product and technology is saying,
"We're launching five
products by Labor Day."
You're starting from ground
zero with five teams.
You've got the blank page problem.
So you panic.
Kind of like when you have to
put together a deck in a hurry
just as an example.
You don't know where to go.
You don't know how to move.
You're stuck.
So here's what's necessary to accelerate.
Have a goal, set a
deadline, drive excitement.
We had a goal, five projects,
five teams in production.
We had a deadline, Labor Day,
which was about five and a
half weeks from that point.
And we had excitement because what we did
is we brought those five
teams together in a room.
We made a lot of noise around it.
It was a big event.
And we said that we're
doing this hard thing.
We're gonna launch five products
and here's what the products are.
They weren't fully flushed out,
but they had a good core around them.
And we're gonna use
agentic AI to deliver them
and to in the solutions that
we are bringing to market.
So you've got the excitement.
Now, what do you do next?
What are our assets?
What are our gaps?
Now let's get moving.
So what do we have?
We were all on AWS.
We're a close partner with them.
We understood what their
product roadmap was
and we had been deeply
engaged with Bedrock.
We were one of the first customers
running Bedrock models in production
and first with access to Clawed.
We had a small team of internal expertise,
a couple of teams that had
built these types of apps.
And we had some ideas,
whether they were good or not,
sort of we didn't know yet.
We needed to get a team together.
Get them into production.
And we had to launch five things.
That's our inventory.
So what do we need?
I'm an architect.
So that's a kind of blank
pages are scary to architects,
especially in new spaces.
So you start out with the
reference architecture placemat.
So this is, what are all of,
we sat down and most of the gray in this
is stuff that we already had solved for.
But there's a lot of white boxes here
that we had to figure out.
Things like cost management
and model monitoring
and orchestration agent
workflows and tools
and API management and orchestration
and how to connect it to our data
and how to see what's going on.
You know where the story is going
'cause Ravi talked to
you about the products
that AWS has put together in
Bedrock and in Agent Core.
But this is a really scary
problem for a lot of teams
'cause it's a blank slate.
They don't know what to do.
So what do we do?
We were on Amazon Bedrock, we
said we're gonna stay here.
We're gonna take a risk
and we're gonna dive into Agent Core.
Agent Core hadn't been released.
It wasn't released until after
we were done with these projects.
We never released stuff into the market.
And again, it wasn't
hyper-scaled at that point.
But we never put stuff on
first generation products,
technology products into market.
We did here because
we'd partnered with AWS,
we saw the roadmap, we
understood what was there.
And we knew how silly it would be
for us to build it ourselves.
And more silly for us
to build it ourselves.
And more silly for our
teams to have to figure out
how to build them themselves.
You heard some of what Ravi
was talking about earlier.
So the next decision we made is,
you get into this conversation
about which agentic framework to use.
And I make the joke,
it's really not a joke,
that there's like a new agentic framework
every two or three days.
And there has been for the last year plus,
just like there's new models every day.
Pick one and go.
What you're doing here,
we'll talk about in a second,
you have the ability to pivot and change.
Especially if you're using agentic AI
to help you do that work.
Pick things and go.
And strands is an AWS
backed open source product
that runs natively.
And at the point we
started was best option
to go in and run on agent core.
And it met all of the needs we had.
The other thing is
agent core, sorry, yeah,
agent core could run other frameworks.
And we could have given one framework
to each of the five teams,
but would that, maybe we
would have learned things,
but we really wanted to
get a market in five weeks.
So let's focus all of our
energy learning one thing
and getting really good at
it and enabling the teams.
So focus is an important part of this.
So we talked a little bit about strands
at the high level architecture level.
Building, we talk about, I think,
as Ravi was talking,
we're talking about agents
and how magical they are
and all the things you have to maintain.
But building an agent
yourself as a developer,
there's only a couple of core
things you do in the agent.
One, you write some text,
which is the prompt.
Two, you make some configuration,
which is usually also written in text.
And three, you attach it to a model
with some configuration parameters.
And then you attach it to some tools
that allow it to do things.
Conceptually, that's all you have to do.
With strands, all you
really have to think about
is what the text you write
is and the tools you use are
and how you take that very
abstract system and make it real.
You're literally just writing
Python as configuration.
In this case, super simple
case from the strands website,
you're bringing in an agent,
you're bringing in a calculator
tool that already exists.
I don't have time today to show you
the implementation of that tool.
But if you looked at it, you'd
see the Python documentation
describing what the tool
is and when to use it
and what the parameter values mean,
just like you should be
doing with any Python
or any source code you write.
It's well documented.
And the strands framework can bring it in
and wire it in automatically.
And then you say to that agent,
"Hey, what's the square root
of whatever that number is?"
This is how LLMs actually solve
math problems, by the way,
or how they should.
You should rely on a
deterministic process to do that.
It really is that simple.
And you can get started in strands
running on your desktop today
or running an AWS
infrastructure in minutes.
So the key message here is get started
and focus your teams in on the
features and functionalities,
not the frameworks and infrastructure.
The language doesn't matter.
Jenna, I can write it for you.
The frameworks don't matter.
There's a hundred of them
and they all do pretty
much the same thing.
Find one that's really
well-supported and run it.
And since you're all here
at the AWS conference,
start with AgentCore and strands.
You can use the other
frameworks as necessary.
So I'd like to invite Tabare up.
And Tabare was the lead architect
for one of the projects we launched,
probably the most successful project,
the most customers using it today.
He's gonna tell you about what he learned
and what the journey was for that.
And then we'll come
together and wrap up on,
maybe we'll tell you how the
rest of the projects went.
- All right, am I on?
Great.
Okay, thank you, BLN, and
good afternoon, everyone.
My name is Tabare Gowon, and as BLN said,
I'm a lead architect at Cox Automotive.
And so just a moment ago,
BLN shared with you our agentic journey,
our company's overall agentic strategy,
and where we're planning to
go with these principles.
Now, I'd like to walk you through
what that's actually looked
like on a product team
at Cox Auto, and hopefully leave you
with some of the patterns
that can guide you
to building your own agentic solutions.
But of course, I'm gonna have
to tell you how we got here.
So let's start at the top.
As BLN said earlier,
it's around 2022, 2023,
and the LLMs are hitting the mainstream,
chat GPT, et cetera.
If you were like our team,
you were probably
thinking around this time,
this tech is actually pretty cool.
I mean, how can we use it?
How can we put it here?
How could we put it there, et cetera?
And so our team, at the end of 2023,
started our first Gen
AI POC, and, oh, great.
At the beginning of this year,
we actually launched that product
called Predictive Insights.
It's a human-in-a-loop
Gen AI message generator
for our company's CRM.
So with Predictive Insights,
as you click a button,
as our dealers click a button,
they can craft personalized
messages to their customers
using all of the data that
BLN mentioned earlier.
And since we launched
in earlier this year,
we've got a lot of good praise.
Our dealers are loving it
because they can move their customers
right alongside their journey
with just a simple click.
But here we have a problem.
Predictive Insights requires
you to actually click a button
and generate a message to the customer.
But the reality is, at the dealership,
more than half of their
leads come in after hours
where there isn't anyone
to click the button.
So we thought to ourselves, all right,
this is working out pretty well.
How can we take what we just built
and move fully autonomous?
And in doing that process,
we realized the actual question was,
how do we build automated AI solutions
that our users will trust?
Because it's one thing to say,
yes, we need to build a solution
that knows a dealer's
voice and knows their brand
and can meet their customer
at any time of the day.
But at the same time, we need to do that
while maintaining safety
and brand reputation
just for us and the dealer,
all without human oversight.
So that became the challenge,
and here's what we built.
So this here is our fully
automated virtual assistant
for customer conversations
at the dealership.
It's built on Amazon Agent Core
and the Strands Agent Framework.
If we start at the top,
we have an orchestrator.
When a customer sends in a new message,
the orchestrator understands that intent
and routes that message down
to one of several sub-agents,
sales, service, and so on.
Each sub-agent now
understands its own domain
and it can handle its
part of the conversation
independently.
So then, once all the
sub-agents are complete,
the orchestrator now grabs
all of that resulting data
and crafts a message back to the customer
and continues the conversation.
And this goes back and forth
for as long as the
conversation is necessary.
Of course, as you can see in this diagram,
there's more to this story.
And sure, we can give you
all of the technical details,
but the reality is, when you're starting
one of these projects,
where do you actually start?
You start with your foundation,
and that foundation is Agent Core.
So, when you're building
conversational assistance,
you know one thing you need is
to keep your data separated.
And as BLN said earlier,
many of you who had your hand up earlier,
you know that these AI
frameworks, they change every day.
So the tools that you
build your solutions today
might not be the tools
that you use tomorrow.
So you're gonna need to
build your infrastructure
on things that are both safe
and that could evolve as
your business evolves.
And this is where Agent Core comes in.
It keeps your data sessions separated,
and it allows you to swap frameworks
without re-architecting your entire stack.
When my team started our process,
the guidance that we
received from several sources
was to start on Agent Squad.
I think this is AWS Labs, don't quote.
But the reality is, by the
time we got into mid-project,
the new guidance was use trans-agents.
This is a more better solution.
Go down that route.
Now normally, in the old days,
this could have taken several
weeks to migrate the project,
but because we had started
with solid foundation,
it only took us two.
So when you're building your solutions,
also start with a foundation
that can evolve with your business,
and that will leave you the
room to think about the problems
that actually matter to
your domain, like safety.
How do you keep these
agentic solutions safe?
Anyone?
For us, we red-team them.
So you might be asking,
all right, what exactly is red-teaming?
Red-teaming now is when you actively try
to make the system go off the rails,
and you can do this in a number of ways.
For our assistant, for example,
you could try asking the assistant
a question in a foreign language.
Another option is maybe
you can feed the assistant
bytes and bytes of unreadable characters.
Or if you're trying to be clever,
you could try to sweet-talk the assistant
to maybe just, maybe
give it its system prompt
or tool definitions.
You're basically trying to find
your system's failure modes.
And now, as you hear this,
you're probably thinking,
okay, isn't this just testing?
No.
Because testing checks what works.
And red-teaming actually
tries to break it.
And you can't leave this
type of solution to the end.
For us, we red-teamed
before our alpha phase,
our beta phase, and we
continue to red-team
as we move to production.
We catalog every exploit,
and then we fix them,
and then we iterate to the next thing.
And we do this after every code deployment
and every prompt change.
Because realistically, your
stakeholders are gonna ask you,
how does this thing break?
And if you do this, you'll
have both the answers
and the examples of what could go wrong.
And then, of course, you're
gonna have to fix it.
How exactly do you fix these solutions?
You use your guardrails.
So, because we're at this conference,
you've probably heard
about bedrock guardrails.
I'm here to say that most of you know
that you need something to prevent AI
from going off the rails.
That's a given.
But when you're dealing
with customer service,
if you only focus on blocking,
you're gonna provide a
poor customer experience.
So, in our opinion, you have
to consider your guardrails
from at least two perspectives.
Something to completely block the system,
as well as something to just
gently nudge the conversation
into a different direction
that you actually want
to do something with.
We call these hard guardrails
and soft guardrails.
Now, with hard guardrails,
the system doesn't even
talk, really, to the LLM.
Usually, these guardrails
sit right on top.
And they're the things that
respond with things like,
"I can't help that," and
the conversation stops.
These are the things
that you can configure
with bedrock guardrails.
On the other hand, soft
guardrails do use the LLM,
but you configure them with your workflow
or your prompt design.
So, for example, let's say,
this is really specific for us,
but I think you'll understand.
Let's say you created a virtual assistant
for the automotive industry.
And in the process of a
customer having a conversation,
the customer says, "Yeah, you know,
"I really do like this car,
but I have pretty bad credit.
"So I was hoping I could get into this
"for maybe 100, 150 a month."
And you've designed your virtual assistant
to solve a lot of problems,
but you don't want it to
handle pricing negotiation.
When you use soft guardrails,
you tune the system
so that it responds with,
"That's a great question
for our finance team.
"Let me schedule an appointment."
And these kind of guardrails allow you
to continue to be helpful
while staying safe.
So think about your guardrails
from both of these perspectives.
All right, so I've
given you a lot already.
But let's just pause for a second.
Let's say that many of you here
are trying to hit that
orange, ready to launch.
And after this conversation,
you've decided,
"All right, let's use Agent Core.
"That'll be our foundation."
And what this guy just
said sounded about right.
I'm gonna go home and
red team my application.
And because we are safe practitioners
of this agentic landscape,
I will also configure my guardrails
so that things don't go off the rails,
and I'll use the soft guardrails.
This point, you should
probably be ready to launch.
Correct?
No, because the reality is,
even if you red team your
system to see if it breaks,
you still actually have to
test that it works, right?
But traditional testing
can only take you so far
because these LLMs are probabilistic.
So you're going to need to find something
that's more dynamic.
All right, we know this.
So what are our options?
Well, we could just manually
review every conversation.
And that will work for a
couple dozen conversations,
maybe a couple hundred conversations.
But when you're dealing
with tens of thousands
of transactions daily, manual
review just won't scale.
So you're gonna have to
look for some other option.
And this is where automated
evaluation comes in.
So what do I mean by
automate your evaluation?
Just as you can use an LLM
to generate these responses,
you can use another LLM to judge
whether or not these
responses are correct.
This approach is called LLM as a judge.
And the process is pretty straightforward.
First, you generate a bunch
of test conversations.
Then you run them through your system.
(coughs)
Then you evaluate, how did it do?
And you track this over time.
Once you have actual data,
you can use the same evaluation framework
to test whether your system is working
for the things that matter.
So this type of testing
actually checks what's right.
For us, we track metrics like relevancy,
completeness, and tone,
things that matter for
customer conversations.
But of course, yours will be different.
So find the metrics that
matter most for your business.
All right, so we're gonna go back
to that previous slide one more time.
We're still here.
We know that agent core
is where we're gonna go.
Red teaming is the
right thing to do, sure.
Better our guardrails and the
soft guardrails, we got it.
And now you know that
not only are you trying
to test what breaks, but you
gotta make sure that it works.
So we're gonna automate our evaluation
so we can scale up for our
actual production needs.
At this point, now you're
ready to launch, right?
I think you already know
where this is going.
No, because like I said just a moment ago,
LLMs are probabilistic, and
you can do all of this work,
and you still will have
the LLM do something
that you least expected.
And the last thing you want is to wake up
to a whopping LLM bill.
So now what do you do?
Well, you need to put
something to stop the system
before it goes off the rails
while you're not around,
and that's where circuit
breakers come in to the mix.
So when I talk about circuit breakers,
I'm talking about the hard limits
that stop the assistant
when things go wrong.
In our case, we consider two
metrics as our hard limits,
cost limits and turn limits.
So for example, let's
say that in the process
of a conversation, we've identified
that the conversation
has hit our P95 threshold
in terms of cost.
At that point, the assistant will stop.
Likewise, let's say that
we're having a conversation
and we've gone back and
forth and back and forth
and back and forth and back and forth,
and all of a sudden, I
don't know why there's a two
and a zero underneath, but let's say
that we've hit 20 turns.
At the same time, our assistant will stop.
In either case, the P99 cost or the turn,
we hand off the conversation
to someone at the dealership
so now they can decide, does
this conversation continue?
So these type of metrics, cost and turn,
those are things that
Bedrock tracks for you,
but it's your job to analyze that data
and set the thresholds
that make the most sense
for your business.
So set these limits from day one
and know where your boundaries are
so that when you fail,
you can fail gracefully
and you can sleep well at night.
All right, so those are
some of the patterns
that we have learned through the process
of getting our project
into beta and beyond,
and let me share with
you where we are today.
So as I just said, we
are right now in beta
and our dealers are seeing
the results that they need.
We're hearing that their customers
are getting the answers that they need
both during the day and after hours.
We plan to launch at the
beginning of Q1, so stay tuned.
And that's really all I have right now.
Your system, however,
is gonna look different
because your requirements
are understandably different.
But if you start with
the right foundation,
like Agent Core, and focus
on the patterns that matter,
you also can create your automated
AI that your users trust.
Thank you.
- So I promised you we'd come
up and tell you how we did,
but before you do that,
who thinks, you saw one,
who thinks that's the only success we had?
Oh, come on, someone's
gonna be negative, right?
Who thinks we knocked
all five out of the park?
So thank you, I appreciate your faith.
Let's talk a little bit about it.
So we had five projects.
Today we have three apps in
production in a beta format.
The first one to be going full live
is the one that Tabare's
talking to you about.
We have an app going into production
that's actually being used in dealerships
that essentially, when
you price inventory,
there's a lot of work you have to do.
And we remind people to do
it and they don't do it.
And so we built an agentic
solution to do it for them.
And instead of nagging
them to do the work,
we said, hey, I did the work
for you, are you good with it?
And then we'll move that into
full agentic moving forward.
So that's another type
of product we built.
We built a couple others.
So three are in production today.
One's about to launch a little bit later.
And let's just say one we
took back to the drawing board
and reimagined.
That actually is probably
some of the most valuable
data we got is what didn't work, right?
What I'll tell you is
agentic systems are hard.
The hardest thing that we ran into is in,
this is a soft way of programming.
It's not deterministic.
This whole thing is non-deterministic.
And so the way you think about products
and the way you think
about capabilities here,
agents have agency, they
can do what they want.
You have to put the guardrails around,
but that's a hard thing for
people to wrap their mind around
from a product point of view.
So what were our lessons?
Let's talk really quickly
about our lessons today.
So the first lesson is get moving.
Nobody's an expert.
There's some great, Amazon
has some great offerings
here in Bedrock and Agent Core.
Strands is an option,
but there are a bunch of,
like as you heard, any agentic
framework can run on it
if you prefer something different.
The other is to think disruptively.
Many people would not have said,
we're taking five
projects and putting them
with live production traffic
with customers in five weeks.
That seems insane, right?
Start with crazy and work backwards.
Agenic AI lets you fundamentally
change your assumptions.
You can use it to build systems faster
than you can ever imagine before,
and you can have it build things
that you could never imagine.
And so the embrace of agentic is key,
and you need to be
using agentic every day,
not just as engineers,
but as product leaders,
as engineering leaders, as architects,
because until you get past
the fundamental understanding
that agentic is different,
you can't understand how
to build agentic products.
I talked a little bit
earlier about chatbots.
Tabare's application is
far more than a chatbot.
You have those multiple agentic layers.
There's a chatbot agent with other agents
back in the background doing work.
You can build tools like deep research.
You can build tools that essentially
invert the shopping funnel
so that you give customers,
just click on this button
and you can buy it.
There's all kinds of things you can do
that are not just chatbots.
Think beyond chatbots.
But you've gotta use it every day
'cause it's gonna change the way you work.
So, Tabare.
- Yeah, so when you're
thinking about those things
and you start building,
what can you start with right after this?
Number one, start red teaming today.
I know it says tomorrow, but start today.
Learn how your system breaks.
Learn how to break your system
and do these things before
your customers get to it first
so that you can set up your guardrails
and prevent some of those
things happening down the line.
Second, design for your worst case.
If you already have an idea
of what kind of keeps you up at night
with what your agentic solution could be,
build your evaluation
framework around that
so that over time you can see
whether or not that was
truly the worst case
and whether or not you've mitigated
the crisis from occurring.
And then finally, as I said before,
even if you do all these other things,
things will still go wrong.
Just to let you know, things
will probably still go wrong.
So set your hard limits.
Understand what your thresholds are.
Understand what your boundaries are
so that when you do have these failures,
you can fail gracefully.
And if you do those things,
you'll be all right.
- So to wrap this up,
we're at AWS re:Invent.
And so I was thinking about like
what's the right message to land this on?
Today's your day one.
This is a Bezos quote.
Day one is a core Amazon philosophy.
We work very closely with them.
We talk about day one and
we adopt it in our practices
and try to model it.
Day two is stasis followed by irrelevance,
followed by excruciating painful
decline, followed by death.
And that's why it's always day one.
Get moving.
Don't be stuck in waiting
for someone else to do this
or the right answer.
Get moving and build something
in five weeks or one.
So I want you, there's a
couple of resources here.
There's a QR code for leveling up skills.
And there's a QR code
for the Asian Core Deep
Dive hands-on workshops.
I highly recommend that.
It's a great way to get your hands on
and see how easy it is
to build these things.
And so definitely scan
those with QR codes.
And please, please, please
complete the session survey
in the mobile app.
We'd love to hear your feedback
and how we could do better.
And thank you very much.
If you have questions, we'll
be up here for a little while.
We've got a few more minutes
before we need to relinquish the room.
So thank you very much for
being in attendance today.
(audience applauding)